the other day i'm doing a zoom and one  of my guys is asking a question it's  about 12 people on the call one of the  guys asked a question and says pat how  do i know when i get home  that i had a productive day how do i  know that i've had a productive day or  not that's a great question i said let's  go ahead and qualify i said here's what  i want to know i want to know with you  it says what's that i said i i want you  to qualify  what is a terrible day for your business  what is a bad day what is a good day  what's a great day so let's start off  with tell me  what makes you think you get home you're  in bed it's 10 30 11 o'clock you're  laying next to your wife you're saying i  had a great day today in business what  made it a great